stories don't have to be true that ended
by by including elements of the
fantastic elements of fable of myth or
mythological elements or fairy tale just
or just you just pure make-believe you
can actually start getting at the truth
in a different way it's another it's
another door into the truth and that's
why I think the thing that is
interesting about the phrase magic
realism is that when it's used
people tend only to hear the word magic
so they think it's just about fantasy
but the word realism is as important and
and what this kind of writing tries to
do is to be grounded in the real to be
grounded in an actual quite strong
vision of the real and then use
techniques to express that vision which
don't necessarily have to be realistic
the thing about magic realism so-called
is that it's a new ish name for a very
old thing you know and this particular
name came into being in Latin America in
the nineteen nineteen 50s and and was
used to describe a group of writers
borås Garcia Marquez vargas llosa Julio
Cortazar Alicia Carpentier and several
others who used techniques which
diverged from straightforward
naturalistic writing then they used
elements of fantasy and dream and and
included those in in the text of the
story as if they have the same state
status as observable facts no I mean
I've always been as a writer from the
very beginning I was interested in in
this general area of a fiction I mean I
started out you know as a young person
long before I wrote
thing I was very very interested in
science fiction and I read and I read
the enormous amount of science fiction
in my teens and early 20s and actually
my first novel drivers which was
published more or less just over 40
years ago was really in that area it was
it wasn't very modern science fiction
but it was certainly fantasy fiction you
know because I think that that form of
what might be better called speculative
fiction has always been a very good
vehicle for the novel of ideas you know
if you have if you have ideas that you
want to set in motion and interrogate
and argue about you know science fiction
fantasy fiction has always done that
always done it very well so I always had
that interest and I mean that interest
in in that kind of jorah fiction
combined with my knowledge of Eastern
fable and folktale and fairy tale you
know and all of that went towards
turning me into the the writer that I
became